well you're in like a great position as
a musical artist because you do have
like a a real career the very thriving
acting career thank you man well and
there's a strike right now right so like
yeah how's that so for people who don't
understand because I think it's not
working yeah they not they out of work
because all we do is hear about this
Rider strike and my uh you know my kid
goes to school in Burbank so you know it
so some of his friends uh like parents
are like uh stuntman or yeah everybody
is Gang [__] so I'm so nobody is working
bro let me break this [__] down for you
it's gang [__] when you get in the union
they taxing your ass you don't even want
to be in the union they like hey bro so
are you with the writers I'm with
writing d uh I think I'm a DJ I'm not
sure sag you know I mean are you like
you you agree with the writers going on
strike like it's uh bro this gang [__]
it don't matter okay like it's
gangbanging
yeah so like if if they strike everyone
strikes well yes well
yes now and thank God but it's not
always been like that there's like inner
things fighting but we're all coming
together because we all got the same
plight now the problem is that profits
have expanded massively egregiously
um and they in in the compensation has
remained the same much like an American
culture with like the um minimum wage
everything minimum wage is raised to
like two something twelve dollars it
does not it does not reflect inflation
right at all inflation is like I don't
know 10x or some [__] and then the
minimum wage is moved up a few cents or
whatever that's the same thing that's
happened with writers now for me I'm
from a place where like one writer's
check that it is right now can change my
whole life and everybody's life when I'm
from so it's hard for me to relate as an
individual but as a body and a group of
people who are trying to set a standard
so that egregious acts aren't Happening
by people at the top I gotta support it
it's true yeah the math is math it is
what it makes sense it makes sense why
they're striking it makes sense and they
need to so for you is is your stars
filming put to a whole
I didn't know if you were in the middle
of shooting or like well well we was
literally the day I was supposed to go
back to shoot like they was like wait
wait hold up but a lot of the scripts
were already written so we may still go
back because everything's written right
which means we're technically in the
clear for some of the scripts this is
where it gets tricky when so this is
where it gets tricky because
the most gangster of all the unions
ISC and um the truckers like the the
truck dude producer driving the trucks
and they don't get equipment [__] they
they have a we don't cross picking
Line's policy it's mandatory it's gang
banging so even though they are
contractually obligated to show up to
work if W.J sag or DJ show up and they
like form a picket line at any
production they won't cross they ain't
Crossing it so the secret is and I'm
probably snitching too much but it is
what it is if they if we can get to you
we gonna get on your ass and they're not
Crossing so [__] get stopped you feel me
and that does affect everybody's pocket
because then nobody's working
Productions Get slowed down things ain't
happening I've been blessed enough to
have been making a massive pivot or not
even a pivot but I was doing music well
you can focus on music a little bit more
now oh yeah I got the you see I got man
when I played this right I'm look I'm
baking all I have on music and at first
it sounded stupid to everyone around me
because they don't understand right but
when you come from nothing you wrote in
the dice bro you going in and now it
looks like I'm brilliant because my
homies ain't working and you are and
you're able to work on this other thing
you got going correct that's the beauty
of being independent like I funded my
own [__] bro okay nobody tell me stop
and quite frankly like okay I'm in
solidarity with the writers and actors
and all that but this gives me time to
work on my own spec my own movies my own
music my own TV my own the show you're
on is that the same show Joey Badass is
on yes it is that's my brother we gotta
we got a record too how about I say you
guys got to do a record we got a whole
we got a whole types of [__] he's a
great actor oh yeah now he turned it
into a sex symbol too you know
I was at the [__] mall
oh yeah I can't wait till I get mine
can't look under underground rap homie
is over here Bowman dabson had Calvin
Klein first thing I did was take a
picture of him be like look at your
girlfriend I'm so happy for him and then
you know Joey got Paco Rabanne you know
the homies is really getting into these
spaces I'm like I can't wait to get mine
I might be a little too rough though but
they they should look fly okay